I am the other defy the CEO of Tom
welcome to microfinance institution and
social into preneur joined the family of
schwa T's for the World Economic Forum
two years ago actually this year the
conference is about job creation and
unemployment and I think from my
perspective and my speciality actually
is my two entrepreneurs and micro
businesses is maybe one of the tools
that would be used to to create
employment actually to fight against the
unemployment but it's not the only it is
not the only tool but I think one of the
important tools that could be used for
job creation and this could happen
through government support through
public-private partnerships and it's not
the only it's not only the
responsibility of government that it's
the responsibility of all parties even
educational systems that that could
incentivize the Entrepreneurship skills
intrapreneurship mentality and mindset
in in the Arab world because one of the
very important factor here that we are
most of the Arab world and before Darb
explained that we were talking about
just employment secured a job and this
is what I want to do my interest of my
life but now I think we should foster
and incentivize the people and the kids
and they used to think about
intrapreneurship and how they could
start with self-employment for
themselves first and then to create more
jobs for the rest of the youth in the
Arab country